you are in england and i understand you
guys just went into lockdown again
is that right yeah our our second wave
um we just come out actually but uh
it it went went crazy again um and so
yeah we're on our second lockdown just
for one
uh one month to sort things out so right
yeah
it's like this year's been no different
to me i don't know whether in lockdown
or not
really it doesn't make a lot of
difference to me i've i never like
people coming to the house i've always
got enough booze for a nuclear winter
so i'm always on the couch in my pajamas
by six o'clock watching netflix so the
evenings literally haven't changed
so it suits me but this is good i like
this as well i i
the fact that i don't have to see you in
person or smell you
is good you know what i mean it makes a
i think i understand
yeah i'm happier i'm certainly happier
in this interview than our previous
yes yes ricky you've always complained
you've always complained
and to be fair to you for many years
when you would come on the show you'd
say i'd love to do this but over
zoom i'd love to be six thousand miles
away from you
yeah what is great which makes me think
how terrible
we had a pandemic before in the 17th
century
the great plague and there was no zoom
and that was awful yeah that was
dreadful
right you know you go people back said
many history many people wrote back in
their journals back then if only there
was a way we could speak to each other
with kind of crappy resolution and a lag
time
wouldn't our lives be better so
ricky this has to be tough for you
because i've known you for a while and
let me point out also we're on different
time schedules so you're not drinking
alcohol
early in the morning um i want to make
that very clear to people
i mean i'm hardly drinking alcohol it's
beer which is a soft drink
in england
that's what you think when you're
hungover just to get yourself back
into your hair i forgot that in england
in ireland uh when you go to a
restaurant you buy a child a beer
instead of like uh
yeah yeah even if it's not your child
you just say drink
drinks for all the kids you're a rich
american
you go to dublin i've done that i've
done that many times children
of ireland guinness for all the kids
while i'm here um listen i've known you
for a while you're a bit of a
hypochondriac you worry constantly about
your health
and your well-being so
anything how are you handling a plague
we have a modern-day plague
how's that going well for the first
few days of the lockdown every other day
i thought i'd caught it i said to jane
i've definitely i've got a temperature
she'd go no you haven't she even bought
a thermometer
online so she could go no you haven't
right
and then i'm i always think the worst
and i google it as well
so if i find a lump i think well that's
that's terminal
it could be a pimple or anything at the
moment though
um to be fair though i'm sometimes right
like i had root canal work
and uh um i went to the dentist and they
were all in their
gear and everything and uh and now i've
got a gun boil
so all that i've got a gum a gum boil a
gum boil
what is it i've got a i've got a um
a bad [ __ ] a gun boyle i've got bad back
bad knees and i do complain right and i
think oh i'm gonna die
but one day i will be right in fact
as time goes on i've got more and more
chance
of being right have a night it's not my
nerve used to do this
for the last 20 years of my nan's life
she'd go
oh i won't see christmas this year and
the last year she was right
so what i mean
infection it was an infected tooth um
they gave me some
a prescription to get uh some
antibiotics and i went to get the
antibiotics
and the pharmacist said oh um
don't drink alcohol with these because
they make you violently sick
so i came home and told jane and she
went i'd be good
um not out drinking for a few days and i
went
i'm gonna drip i'm not gonna drink the
i'm not going to take the antibiotics
right and she went you've got to take
the antibiotics so i compromised
and i drank and took the antibiotics
and i woke up that night in a sweat
feeling sick
going i've got corolla virus she said
remember you drank and took the
antibiotics
oh yeah yeah i i remember
i did just what they told me not to do
i want to ask you about a boil nobody's
had a boil
in in like 400 years no one gets a boil
anymore that's uh
that's something that some middle age i
know 1400 is disease
it's really weird um i've got a gum boy
i've got some wrong on the feet like
chill blind or something or
i don't know um what am i gonna get next
a goiter
i mean why am i suffering from those
things
i i went to the doctor and then i had
all over medical last year
and at one point he said you're pre gout
pre
gout scout what does that mean um
it's urea in the bloodstream so i think
from
booze and uh yeah i had it all over
medical
i feel like those things right and i
tell the truth
except units of alcohol and i always
halve those
yeah when the doctor gets to those he
goes oh that's a lot i think i've won
i go is it you know
[Laughter]
so your doctor thinks it's a lot even
when you cut the number
of glasses you have a day in half your
doctor says it's too much yeah but that
what are the i mean they just make these
figures up don't they it's fine
also people say to me if you if you gave
up
booze you'd live ten years longer i
think yeah but they'll be the last ten
years
they're the rubbish ten i don't want
those ten years if i can have like
20 to 30 again that'd be great but
you've got to have
80 to 90 and um that's that's no fun
i've seen 90 year olds sitting in an
armchair right and they suddenly go oh
what i've broken every bone in my body
you just get brittle
and i just think it's no much just
just have fun and then die kids
do you mind if we put that together for
a public service announcement that we've
won
here in america just have fun and then
die kid says ricky
my body like an old car i don't need a
new one i can't have a new one right
it's going to work
i'm just going to have as much fun and
just break down and they just have to
tow it away
and crush me and i you know and you know
we're all going to die
so being healthy is just dying more
slowly
so i i'm not gonna stop anything you
know
i don't i i don't i this is the most
dangerous thing i do
ever i'm sitting down at home right
and then and it turns out someone can
just cough on you
and kill you well that no one you know
i'm beginning to think i i wish i hadn't
eaten all those bats
for christmas what said you ate them raw
that's the problem you need to
thoroughly cook a bat before you eat it
ricky
rose were into your raw bats which